[Music]
this is star talk neil degrasse tyson
here your personal astrophysicist i got
with me my co-host chuck chuck always
good to have you there man always a
pleasure to be here neil you bring a
force of levity to all content that
has gravity on this program
see and listen
even when you talk uh comedy you still
do it in science terms
it's still i mean the terms are still
astrophysical when you're talking about
well i think the universe is hilarious
so that's why so today's topic are
science pioneers oh science pioneers we
don't do this as often as we should it's
all these are good topics because all
kinds of scientists out there that uh
you know might not have made headlines
but
they're there and they're getting the
job done let me ask you this as a
scientist yes
do you think
that it's better to be on the cutting
edge
and risk being ahead of your time
or to be
um
in the sweet spot and perhaps either
prove or make the big discovery
just i both
why why you got to make everything
binary chuck we live in a spectrum world
when yeah we got we've got a guest today
who has some expertise in finding
scientists who are pioneers and are
worth talking about and we've got danny
washington danny welcome to star talk
thank you very much hey what's up it's
so good to be here i'm really excited
i've been looking forward to this for a
very long time excellent and you'd
remind me we had met several years ago
you had attended a live um recording of
star talk at the american museum of
natural history under the sphere of the
hayden planetarium so it's great to have
you sort of back in the fold yeah
totally full circle
you've been busy the last few years and
first you've got a podcast called the
genius generation podcast
and
i'm guessing it's not my generation who
messed up the earth
well no not quite it's definitely not
your generation and it's not even my
generation oh okay
that's all it counts
this uh this podcast is awesome because
it focuses on young people under the age
of 18 who have either found a recent
discovery or created new businesses that
are changing the game in different
realms of stem and i had so much fun
interviewing these young people they're
brilliant and it made me realize like
what am i doing with my life these kids
are like 12 years old making you know
incredible discoveries and you're like
what
don't don't worry danny don't worry
they're just peaking early okay
okay they're going to burn out here
later
by time they're 26 they'll be washed up
oh my gosh well you know after covid oof
you know so danny you're you're an ocean
person and i don't think we have enough
of such people in this world the ocean
is you know most of earth's surface and
so much we don't know and frankly you
know space kind of siphons off a lot of
what
could be attention also given to earth's
surface
by surface i mean including the oceans
you know earth the planet and so uh
you're a founder of an ocean
conservation organization who gets to
say that okay yes you are accomplishing
things danny
stop stop using 12 year olds as a metric
for whether you succeeded so it's called
big blue and you so tell us about that
well you know i received my bachelor of
science degree in marine biology back in
08 at the university of miami and that
was my dream all throughout high school
was to study marine science and then
after undergrad i realized hey like
there's a there's a gap there's a gap in
information between the science
community specifically the ocean science
community and the general public i grew
up in miami and so i was constantly at
the beach in the ocean i was certified
as a scuba diver at 17 and i just knew
that i want to spend as much time as
possible in the ocean but i also wanted
people around me my family my community
to truly fall in love with the ocean
like i fell in love with the ocean
because it's such an important critical
place for all humans on earth
danny is it really true that with scuba
diving all the instructions that you
have to follow oats so that you don't
die
rather than that you have fun is that
true well it's semi true yes it is a
dangerous activity and you can like
no it's very true you need to so we
shouldn't be surprised that as a
resident of miami people there have a
first
you know a front row seat in the
behavior of the ocean yes right i mean
not only with hurricanes but you look at
a map of the future uh uh sea level rise
and florida's gone yeah it's just gone
underwater is that part of it is that
part of the baptism that you experienced
growing up yeah well excuse the term
the baptism oh yeah
well you know to be honest when i was
younger in high school i didn't know as
much as i know of as we know now about
climate change and the impacts of that
and so but i knew that things were not
quite right i looked at different areas
like mangrove forests the sea grass beds
places where i love to explore as a kid
and i saw them changing before my eyes
also beach erosion happening around and
different beaches that i love to visit
so it became evident pretty quickly that
i was like okay we've got some issues
here and we need to start spreading the
word about what's going on out there
because with the ocean it's out of mind
and out of sight for so many people even
people who live right there on the beach
and they don't recognize that under
those waves there's a whole other
universe
i i think of it as a universe it's inner
space that we
use that word on this show
i like that term whatever you need
permission to use that word that way um
could you tell us this this is something
i learned i was like a full grown adult
and i said what is that what they're
called these trees that grow at the
intersection of land and waterways
mangroves
mangroves
why what does that even mean and why so
sexist
you know i that's a great question i've
never even thought about that but i have
no idea why they they gain the name
mangroves but all i know is that they
play an essential role in in places like
florida and across the entire world
around the tropical areas and regions
because they serve as a buffer so
whenever hurricanes come in it's
protecting the land it's also a nursery
ground for so many different marine
species including sharks and reef fishes
and it's where the babies grow up and
they're able to swim out to the reef
after they've grown grown up and so we
need it desperately and and a lot of
times we see in developed coastal areas
where people want to build huge condos
and cool hotels
we're seeing something
they'll cut down the mangroves yeah
because it's blocking the beach in fact
miami beach the beach that i grew up
going to is not a real natural beach
it's actually filled in with sand every
eight years and re-nourished and it was
formerly in the 19 early 1900s it was a
mangrove forest along the coast but it
was removed to create the beach
wow okay so chuck i think mangrove
should be a new haircut at the barber
shop
in the mangrove let me get my mangrove
going here
that's the man groom that's amazing the
back groom your roommate with the man
grove uh you also you also have a
lifestyle brand who does this you have a
lifestyle brand called the mocha mermaid
so what's up with that totally i know
right wait you're a marine biologist and
a black mermaid
that's me and that's me in a nutshell
yep
that's totally dope okay thank you thank
you i love it well i've always been
fascinated by the idea of being half
fish or half marine mammal and half
human and you know
that's called mentally disturbed by the
way i don't think it is i don't think it
is i the reason is that i've always
wanted to be able to spend as much time
as possible underwater and being a
mermaid or looking into that mythology
that's that's been seen throughout
history human history every culture
around the world has had some type of
ocean or water goddess deity whatever in
their mythology and i think there's
something to that i love the story
behind it um it began in africa with
like mami wata and different ideas in
the religious practices that talked
about these half water beings
anyway long story short i like the idea
of being someone who's connected to the
ocean who's constantly in the water and
i wanted to create a space for uh
community building and to find other
people that look like me that have
melanated skin who also love the ocean
because we've been so underrepresented
in this space uh throughout history and
and now it's time i think for us to
reconnect ourselves to water because
i believe that water is a healing
element it's something that you know
whenever i get in the water i
immediately feel at peace at rest and i
feel rejuvenated afterward and i want
other people to experience that
especially people of color let's get
back to the subject of why we have her
on the show and that's to talk about
science pioneers because you've written
a book on science pioneers and
uh
you told us offline that you began this
during covid and it got published uh
just a few months ago at the end of 2021
so i'm glad you did something productive
during covet which is more than most
people can say oh my gosh yeah instead
of just binging on rick and morty you
actually wrote something so this is
great now did you but did you make
sourdough i mean because if you didn't i
didn't that's another one i'm not a
baker i really don't bake that much
though
so so so who do you want to talk about
first well i'd like to start with vera
rubin who oh i'm sure you're welcome i
mean she's passed but yeah we we we're
she that's my field
astronomy yes
she's amazing
she was born in 1928 and you know she
did some pretty incredible things she
helps prove the existence of dark matter
um you know she also used calculations
to to show that galaxies contain 10
times more dark matter than ordinary
matter
and you know it's really considered one
of the biggest and most important
discoveries in astronomy
wow
all in all in and
i
i heard tell
that because she was sort of you know
born in 1928 and in a scientific field
uh certainly dominated by men
the
um to get access to telescopes requires
uh we have to apply and then they have
to sort of someone in charge has to
allow it
and
you have you have stories about her
trying to just use the same damn
telescope everybody else was using but
so tell us about that so vera rubin was
the first woman in 1965 to use the hail
telescope at the palomar observatory and
this was a major step because before
that women weren't allowed to do that
you know that's the biggest telescope in
the world at the time i mean yes yes it
was incredible that she finally had that
dare her want to use the biggest
telescope
and so
you know clearly you guys are
overcompensating for something
with this giant telescope
right
i feel that i feel that well she had to
work really hard to get to that point
honestly her career before even getting
to that position um was a was a journey
at first you know she wanted to do her
degree in astronomy her bachelor of
science degree most schools wouldn't
accept her finally she got into an
all-girls school vassar college and she
graduated she was the only one from her
class who graduated with a degree in
astronomy and then she went to cornell
and then most again most other
universities wouldn't accept her into
their program because she was a woman
and then finally cornell letter you know
joined the crew and then at age 23 she
started pursuing her phd and she even
had her first child while pursuing her
phd
you know that's badass right there so
badass right
pop out a kid while i'm discovering the
universe yeah try that einstein try that
exactly and in fact she ended up having
four children
successfully you know completing her phd
and all this research and this all these
discoveries happening within her career
alongside her husband you know and they
they just lived an amazing life and it
turns out that all four of her children
ended up pursuing phds in stem fields as
well
wow
and so what's this about bathrooms at
the observatory i heard i heard rumors
about this but you got the untold story
what is that so the story about the
bathroom issue with vera was that there
were no female bathrooms in the
observatory so what she ended up doing
was taking a piece of paper and placed
it right over the men's uh you know
symbol and made her own bathroom and
that i think was very significant in
just the symbolism of it where she made
her place she paved her own way and made
sure that she had what she needed to
pursue her dreams
wow so let me
ask you something so
to get for her to get to where she was
required some kind of tenacity all right
it's it's not
putting up with status quo
but
not
uh not being bitter about it necessarily
she just said i'm doing this
try to stop me right exactly and
and
i i worry that some sometimes people
today
that if it's a force operating against
them and then they just kind of lose
they lose it right and then they recede
rather than continue to push to change
the world because it is not easy to
change the world there's always somebody
who wants to prevent it so
this seems like a
character trait that was very important
definitely
tenacity is definitely the word that i
would use to describe vera because she
made a way when there was no way and
figured out other alternatives for her
to get to where she wanted to go and i
just love that about her and again she
did it while raising a family while
doing everything that you know women
quote unquote are traditionally known to
do while being a badass astronomer
right and in my field we you know we
recognize i mean
we do recognize discoveries basically
you know no matter who it is
and there's some lapses that
occasionally need correction of course
but
um i mean today vera rubin has a
telescope named after her that did you
get to put that in because that happened
only recently
did that get it into your book it didn't
make it in the book but i didn't mention
it because it just happened it just
happened
yeah so
so the current most powerful telescope
in the world is named the vera rubin
telescope and it's it's this humongous
telescope it has the largest digital
camera ever built okay it's the size of
a human being like the detector surface
all right
and you just walk into this camera and
it's designed to take
snapshots of the sky continually which
you can then stitch together and
basically make a movie
of the night sky and the value of this
is think about it just think about this
what have we been doing the whole you
know ever since we've had telescopes
let's get one image in this one moment
that i happen to be looking but suppose
something happens an hour after you shut
off the telescope or you're in the
bathroom or suppose something happened
do you miss that or suppose something
happens only in 24-hour increments and
so you see it and you think it's natural
but it's only doing something for you in
this 24-hour increment and you're
missing all the rest of the time
you can be biased by how the data has
been obtained so this telescope is it's
called a large um
synoptic survey telescope and that was
too many syllables i'm glad we renamed
it no matter who we renamed it to but
not to be renamed for vera rubin and
uh it's the reuben telescope and she's
and when you're the name of a famous
telescope every discovery that comes out
of it your name is attached to it i love
that oh yeah yeah well deserved fitting
legacy that's for sure
absolutely yeah especially because she
never received a nobel prize even though
many of her colleagues did uh throughout
her career
um yeah yeah exactly you mentioned it
that she discovered dark matter in
galaxies
today that that would have clearly won a
nobel prize um it but was sort of
overlooked at the time by the nobel
committee and
uh and other nobel prizes that had gone
to astronomers in the day
one of them went to the discovery of
pulsars to the man in charge of a
project who didn't actually make the
discovery a woman did her name is
jocelyn bell yeah so justin bell is
another one of these people who now you
got him you got to make another book and
put her in it now exactly yep i think we
should do one another one part two hey
danny what are you doing on this show
get get the hell back to work just keep
writing oh my gosh i have so much
respect for authors after writing my
first book oh my gosh
yes and so so that nobel prize for the
discovery of pulsars uh was for
discovery in the late 1960s uh her
discovery of dark matter was in the
early 1970s it was around the same time
but dark matter is still the longest
unsolved problem in the universe
and we still don't know what's doing it
and she was in the middle of it and we
can thank vera for helping us pave the
way
yes yes that's fantastic
all right all right so danny if i could
add that the implications of her
discovery is that everything you see and
know and love in a galaxy the stars the
gas clouds even the black holes and
planets and moons and and and comets
all of that
is
froth
on an ocean maybe you'll like this
analogy danny because
i think i will buy a lot you said
universe before i'm gonna use ocean now
may i okay sure of course if actual
matter is a small fraction of the total
gravity in a galaxy
then everything we know and love is just
froth on a wave that we cannot see
wow wow we can that's a terrible
technology yeah gravitationally but we
don't know what's causing it
so it's really dark gravity
and and so that that that discovery
lives with us to this day
and it remains an unsolved mystery and
she was in the middle of it so you did
good by including her in your book when
we come back can you tell us more people
in your book absolutely and i assume
they're not all from astrophysics so i
want to learn about other topics too
yeah so
excellent uh we've got danny washington
who's recently written about pioneers in
science uh this is on star talk we'll
learn more about it in the next segment
we're back star talk we're talking about
scientific pioneers over the last
century and i got someone who wrote a
book on them danny washington and danny
you you did this i mean your background
is in marine science but you took on
this project because you felt that there
were some scientists who needed some
attention and somebody's got to do it
absolutely
we just came off of a segment talking
about a pioneer in my field vera rubin
um but you also uh tell me some more you
have someone from the field of medicine
yes alice ball alice ball is a chemist
she was born in 1892 and she actually
developed the first cure for leprosy or
also known as hansen's disease back at
the age of 23 years old
okay that's great but if if if she's
born in 1897 and discovered cure for
leprosy that's too late for everybody in
the bible yeah yeah way too late way too
late
[Laughter]
jesus was basically the uh the whole
entire health insurance policy
for everybody of the entire biblical
period
okay
[Laughter]
all right
all right so she's born in 1892 yeah
1892 in watching she did this when she
was 23. man that's a man yeah that's
badass right there so tell me about
leprosy i mean i only you know it sounds
like a like like we were saying like a
biblical disease but what what actually
happens does anyone get it anymore well
people do get it but they're they're
using more modern technology to help
cure it um so they don't use what alice
ball originally created they have new
pharmaceutical products that are helping
but her initial discovery of this
specialized treatment really helped
those suffering
uh not to have to be put away into like
a camp and like taken away from society
now they can actually they were able to
function and what i loved about is that
you know she did it through her own
curiosity and figured out after
researching cava root she was at the
university of hawaii at the time she was
playing with the kava root and then it
moved on to this thing a tree called the
chalmugura tree which is in hawaii and
then she distilled it down and then
figured out if i inject this into the
skin of someone suffering from leprosy
it'll actually heal the sores that end
up wearing
stop stop stop who who does this exactly
there's a tree let me extract this root
boil it down do you want to be a test
subject how does she where does the
thinking come from and who lets you do
that and who lets you tune in you know
so like my arm's falling off you inject
anything into me my arm is going to fall
out you know what you got a point there
you go right right you need some thread
of curiosity that would lead you to
think that this would work at all was
there some traditional indigenous
effects that this already had that she
worked on well not that i remember
researching but i believe that it was
you know already known as like a
medicinal tree and because she was in
hawaii doing her phd and doing her
research there she had access to it and
then her mentor and colleague dr harry t
holman he was one of her biggest allies
who helped push forward because he was
working with leprosy patients and so she
had all this at her fingertips to be
able to help and to create something new
and a new cure that would work
so
for a long while if they put lepers in
leopard colonies which sounds really
it's different i don't know what else
you do in the day but yeah still yeah
yeah you know you don't you don't want
to have to do that going forward no in
and the island of molokai in hawaii is
where there was a specific peninsula
where this colony existed and it was sad
because people would be taken away from
their families and just living you know
day to day and it's just an awful
existence and so her pursuing this cure
was
world changing because so many people
around the world suffered from this
contagious bacterial disease right was
she finally recognized for this work
well you know what ended up happening
was she passed away at the age of 24
tragically she feels goodness what she
just she just discovered the damn thing
and i'm telling you if you tell me she
died of leprosy um
[Music]
she apparently accidentally inhaled
chlorine gas in the lab so it was a lab
accident that ended up happening which
was so sad um and her advisor had to
fight another of one of his colleagues
who published a paper
claiming that her cure was his method
the dean method and it was so
unfortunate harry went along and went
and disputed that but his colleagues
didn't listen and it wasn't until later
in the night the 20th century that a
librarian at the university of hawaii
saw that there was one child moog
retreat on the campus and she did some
research a little digging figured out
that alice was the one who did all this
and then finally many years later she
got some recognition
the lieutenant governor of hawaii
declared february 29th alice ball day in
2000
wow
cool that is pretty cool so wait
so is that so that can't be every year
then
what do you mean it can't be every year
oh yeah because it's a leap year
february correct which is kind of random
yeah i don't know why they would choose
that day i don't know if it was yeah
that's over somebody should have checked
out the calendar on that one
yeah okay so every four years we'll
celebrate
we'll celebrate alice yes
this is like the world cup of scientists
okay every four years four years there
we go i like to make it even more
special
so danny i've got a geeky calendar thing
because i that's one of my
side advocations is thinking about
calendars and yes and whose calendar is
accurate and who's so
in the year 2100 that would normally be
a leap year but in the current calendar
rules it's not
so
really
yeah i will not have a february 29th so
we'll go eight years
without getting to celebrate her
contribution so
so we should just go back to lieutenant
governor of uh hawaii and fix that i
agree change today go there tell him to
call me okay
we'll straighten that out
whatever happened to the dean character
i don't know i didn't do much research
about him the one of one of the other uh
doctors who stole her her cure and
claimed that it was his discovery and it
really was not it really wasn't good
okay well that's all we need to know
yeah okay
all
right
so danny who else do you have well
another scientist that i absolutely
adore uh she's a botanist born in india
named janaki amal so she's known as
india's finest plant scientist and she
pioneered in the field of cytogenetics
and she even has two plants named after
her wait what don't go just go past that
word and not explain it
act like we all know what the hell
you're talking about listen
genetics what is it cytogenetics well
you hear the word genetics in there so
it has to do with the study of
chromosomes but it also talks about the
role of chromosomes in heredity and like
things and traits that are passed down
from different living organisms so in
her case she was studying heredity
within plants which is awesome
yeah yeah and she even developed a new
strain a new type of sugar cane in india
that allowed more people you know to
create more uh sugar products and when
was she doing this now
oh lord this is back in she was born in
1897 so it was early 1900s so she's a
20th century scientist okay yeah yeah i
mean that's that's pretty um i'll say
aggressive
um because
you know right now it's a shame if she
were alive today she would have like the
benefit of these super computers that we
use now to map these things she would
probably be on to some super cool
discoveries oh yeah about it she would
be a rock star like with all the tech we
have now
yeah
it's incredible what she did with what
she had and you know she grew up in
india she had 19 siblings so nance
what's this i heard that she stopped a
damn i mean i don't know what that means
but i heard this said
she stopped the building of a
hydroelectric dam uh on a river that's
in her region where she grew up and that
was significant because there were over
a thousand endemic plants in that
specific area that were found nowhere
else in the world and so she
demonstrated her science and her
activism
just to serve environmental conservation
which is so important and something that
we're still dealing with to this day you
know trying to protect areas of this
planet that are crucial for our health
and and stability in the future
or to even think that way because any
most people yeah damn will bring
electricity you know you're not even
thinking about the biodiversity of what
you will end up flooding to make that
happen exactly for her to be on that
page that's that's very that's brave and
early yes but at least we'll have
electricity that will allow us to see
how badly we empty
there it goes yep we can turn the light
[Laughter]
that reminds me of a gary larson comic
where there's this there's this man and
his son and they just saw down this big
huge tree and the tree that you see the
the the stump of the tree it says up
look son these tree rings uh they
represent all
uh
it says something like
this tree ring was when it survived a
hurricane and this other one was when it
survived it's just pointing towards a
wildfire
yeah great to all the things that the
trees survive
yep yep and then you just cut it down
just like that i just cut it down i like
cut it down that makes no sense
so dana danny i want on my business card
to say i've stopped a damn that's just
yeah right a whole damn a whole damn i
mean
she like she spoke up for nature when
nature didn't have a voice in our human
experience right and what i love about
her is also like she talked about how
like the biosphere in a lot of ways will
go on with or without us and i think
that's something that's important for
all of us to recognize like maybe the
environment will look different after
we've altered it with our own selfish
ways but it's going to go on like we're
just going to wipe ourselves out if we
continue on this path of destruction
but nature will come back yeah one day
you'll see meerkats living in our condos
covered with vines yeah
all popping their heads out the windows
meerkat of all the animals meerkats yeah
that's a random choice
somebody's seen the lion king too many
times right there
have you ever watched meerkat manor
that's like an awesome show it's very
dramatic i have no idea but now i'm
going to check it out but check it out
if you say check it out i should check
it out
the beer cats if they're anything
they're curious right
did you see that oh my gosh like hey hey
hey
so what's that phyto geography i see
that in my notes here well it's really
just a mapping of where plants are
located and so she also did that with
that area and helped establish the
silent valley national park in kerala
india in that same area so the place
where they were going to flood she made
it into help make it into a national
park which is incredible
so let me just ask this about this well
neil you did it on on cosmos but for
either one of you there was this uh
episode that you talked about this kind
of noah's ark for seeds where they take
all the seeds from all over the world
and put them someplace where they'd be
safe if i'm not mistaken
yeah noah's ark is
no
i wanted live animals not to see right
right so it's kind of a broke-ass noah's
ark
yeah it's limited so danny what do you
know what do you know about this so
there's a seed bank that exists there
where there are hundreds of thousands of
seeds that we currently have on the
planet being stored in case of an
apocalypse so that's basically if an
asteroid hits
do we have something to work with and
can we kind of some places other than
norway right in norway correct that part
is very important well it is it's like
the library in alexandria let's put all
the books in one library where they're
safe the library burns down now you got
nothing right nothing so maybe we need
two seed banks at antipodal sides of the
earth that would make sense i like that
idea as long as you keep them away from
vladimir putin we're going to be fine
keep it away from it
[Laughter]
unless we had to just put it there and
put it next to him and put him and put
it in russia so that we know for sure
nothing would happen
i don't know okay so you have the seeds
but you need thing so
is the seed all you need to just restart
there is so much more we live in this
beautiful biosphere that has so many
different moving parts and i mean just
with plants alone especially crop plants
that we use for food we need bees we
need pollinators butterflies to help
spread the pollen and actually continue
the cycle so we we've got a lot of work
to do and it can't just depend us merely
on the seats
well i saw an episode of dark a black
mirror where they
um they had a b drone yes
that i didn't see that episode
oh yeah yeah brilliant
and because if the show is called is
black mirror um
things don't end well
but but the idea was great you know
you're running out of bees just invent a
new kind of
b drone and then there you have it by
the way there's a there's a sequel
coming out uh where every show ends
happily it's called white privilege
mirror whoa
instead of black
here's your seat at the table sir there
you go
everything turns out great for you
everything's gotta be about being black
with chuck chuck it's only
it's only because i live in america
right exactly
all right we're gonna take a break when
we come back more from danny washington
we learn all more about her and uh who
she's written about in her book on
scientific pioneers on star talk
we're back star talk we got a really fun
episode going here with danny washington
who's a
a ocean
danny what what shall we call you if we
gave you a title mourinho
i have my marine biology degree um but
i'm not a practical researcher and you
also have a a
a lifestyle
moniker
the mocha mermaid that's right okay
to put both of those on your business
card that's right you know that's all
you need right there
oh yeah everybody
what are your what are your biggest
platforms there oh my personal platforms
you can find me at danny washington on
all instagram twitter facebook danny
with an i yes danny washington thank you
for clarifying yep danny with it i too
ends and washington spelled like the
state
right on oh d not two ends in washington
but two ends in danny two ends in danny
exactly yes okay
washington would be even better
washington washington
and that is your handle for which
platforms all platforms so you can find
me there you can also follow my
organization big blue and you it's a
non-profit out of miami where i'm from
and we teach young people about the
ocean through art and science combined
and we love it it's called it's big blue
in you on all platforms as well well
wait and your and your podcast which
also
reaches for younger audiences you're
trying to sh you're i know what it is
yeah
yeah i figured this out yeah
when you figure out she's gonna be queen
of the universe right because she's
training this whole next generation of
people that's how you do and then and
then they will just follow her every
command
and then they take over the world and
they and they get and they render they
get rid of us
admit it here on star talk danny this is
your plan
you found out your world domination plan
danny
we caught you we know what it is
listen i gave up on adults a long time
ago okay kids are where it's at yeah
they they know what's up i know this
much you've inspired me
you are the
mermaid i am going to now be the coco
comedian coco comedian
[Laughter]
you're hilarious
so i we got time for like one more
person is there someone else who's like
special to you oh my gosh profiled in
this book yes my favorite and chuckle i
have to explain to chuck chuck when i
say she profiled it it's not a cop thing
you know that's where i was going neal i
know just from saying i just have to
clear you i think preempt chuck's
that okay so profiled in your book yes
who else you have dr sylvia earl who is
my role model and mentor and someone
that i know me some children she's a
friend of star talk she's been on it i
think a couple of times but many years
ago how's she doing what tell me about
her oh my gosh she's what i don't know
about her just keep going bring it bring
it on totally totally well you know she
i met her when i was 17 years old in
florida i was at this national
geographic sleepover event at a museum
so random but she happened to come
because she's a resident um explorer and
that was the first time we interacted in
person well just to be clear nacho has a
title called resident explorer correct
yes
you know who else had that title is
james cameron so the national geographic
likes people who get out there and who
are well known and who would get the job
done so that's a great title to have so
keep going it really is i mean that was
kind of like the cherry on top of her
career because she did so much in her
you know younger years as well as now i
mean she travels more than 200 days out
of the year to give talks and film a
netflix show like she's done all these
different things
but she was born in 1935 in jersey and
then she moved to florida when she was
12 with her family and that's where her
love for the ocean began she used to
explore the coast and like dig through
seaweed on the beach we called it a rack
line and look for little invertebrates
and things that were living in the
seaweed
would you do that chuck would you would
you would you would you have joined
sylvia doing that i don't like sand
danny i'm sorry no sand i don't know
yeah chuck is chuck is still in new
jersey at this moment i just never left
jersey right
imagine what kind of a great scientist
you could have been had you moved from
new jersey
[Laughter]
if only if only
if only if only
again that reminds me the gary larson
comic where where uh jimi hendrix is
like ready to walk into an accordion
store
and it's just and the store happens
happens to be closed but the guitar
store next door is open so that he goes
into the guitar that's pretty funny
okay so i didn't know so she moved to
florida and got ocean influence just the
way you were that's exactly
commonality so tell me more
so she continued that to follow that
passion and then she ended up going to
duke university uh for her master's in
phycology where she studied algae she
collected over 20 000 algae samples
which i believe she donated like
vicology no
phycology like physics phycology
i never that's the first i've ever heard
that word
p-h-y-c-o-l-o-g-y that's it
is that for phylum or something like
what phyto
phyto yeah i believe it's from fido but
it's a study of of of
algae and seaweeds in the ocean
okay so algeology never doesn't run off
the tongue so no not quite
geology okay go on sorry i interrupted
no worries so yeah she she continued
with that path i think she donated her
samples i believe to the smithsonian to
the museum of natural history that
should be still there today and then she
became the first woman appointed as the
chief scientist at noaa the national
oceanic and atmospheric administration
the government agency who handles all
things ocean and atmosphere
indeed yes
yes so she's a badass so she spends time
does she an underwater person or above
water taking samples well we know her as
the her deepness that's literally her
title because she's logged thousands of
hours underwater um in the 1960s she led
a team of of all women aquanauts living
underwater for two weeks at this uh this
housing thing in the virgin islands
called the tech type 2 and that was the
first time that ever happened and it was
just them underwater living for 14 days
doing research not coming up to the
surface it was all self-contained and
she also holds the world record for the
uh the deepest untethered dive in
history
wow
if you're not tethered how do you like
come back up
well she was in this special dive suit
called a gym suit and it was all again
self-contained and she rated herself i
could do that you could do that too not
g-y-m
j-i-m
j i am sorry sorry yes yes and so she
she she woman did i'm not gonna say
mandate but she woman did herself and
went down 1200 feet to be more specific
to 1250 feet
on her own
wow in the pacific ocean
i mean can you imagine the bravery of
that by the way
nasa has addressed this issue of is it a
manned crew so they just they just call
it a crude vehicle c-r-e crude okay yes
yeah so so she she crewed a a vessel or
a an outfit down to the yeah so that's
how nasa handles that so you don't have
to say woman did
there we go she recruited gender neutral
yeah sure okay sure
it's a good idea yeah but she's done so
many incredible things in her her life
you know so far and i see her on the
road before kovit i was going to a lot
of summits and events related to ocean
conservation and she's usually always
there and i just love to hear her speak
about her her passion she always speaks
from the heart but then throws in her
science and she's really become an icon
in our space for sure um and i just
appreciate all the work that she's done
to to you know not only for women in the
space but for everyone to recognize the
importance of the ocean
now we realize you like her but has she
accomplished anything
listen
she's accomplished so much
you should check out her netflix
documentary uh called blue uh
mission blue uh definitely check that
out on netflix
okay okay that's interesting because i
think disney had a ride called mission
space
so this is using that same concept that
you are on a mission yeah and now the
mission is not only discover about the
ocean but do something about it because
we are
uh abusing it badly i mean so so tell me
about your conservation efforts and how
they resonate with sylvia's are you
carrying the torch that she
first lit in this space as you say well
i'd like to think that i am contributing
to that i know that there are a lot of
other phenomenal female marine
scientists out there and
conservationists who are doing a lot of
work so we're we're in it together you
know
but um but sylvia just go ahead and take
the crap
take some
danny it's okay already exposed that
you're
credit
she's going to be everybody's overlord
very soon yeah the next generation will
come up
so what do you what do you see is the
most pressing issue right now when it
comes to the care for our oceans what
what is is it is it microplastics is it
the
warming of the ocean itself the
acidification is it uh wow okay chuck is
is it our you know my boy chuck is just
listen listen
you took the words out of my mouth
[Laughter]
how do we prioritize this danny well
it's again as i mentioned earlier in the
episode i talked about the fact that the
ocean is out of sight and out of mind
for many many people around the world um
but the ocean provides every other
breath the oxygen that's in every other
breath every second breath comes from
the ocean um and it also helps stabilize
our climate on this planet and so what
to answer your question chuck i think
the most pressing issue with the ocean
is the warming of the ocean and the
acidification so two really kind of in
tandem
uh because you know with without the
oceans being in balance and and
stabilizing our climate like we're going
to experience some extreme weather which
we already have been right we've seen it
all over the world but also the fact
that it's acidifying where there's too
much carbon dioxide going in the ocean
it's messing up the balance the chemical
balance of the ocean which causes things
that build their shells underwater like
crabs shrimp but also coral reefs they
use the calcium carbonate out of the
water to create literally create their
bodies they can't do that when the water
is acidic and so that's one impact
but we can we can actually change it and
that's what i love about the ocean so
much it is extremely resilient and if we
give it time and space it can bounce
back in certain ways it may not look the
same as it looked maybe 20 50 100 years
ago we see that now but i think the
ocean can come back and one of the
solutions that i really lean on is blue
carbon and looking at how we can plant
more or create and
how we can establish more marine plants
in the water that actually absorb that
carbon dioxide so i'm talking about kelp
i'm talking about mangroves i'm also
talking about sea grass beds these are
ecosystems that absorb
carbon dioxide out of the water and the
atmosphere 50 times more effectively
than trees on land it's crazy wow
so it's it's the equivalent of of like
doubling forestry efforts yeah doing it
in the in the ocean itself of course the
ocean is way bigger there's a bigger
tapestry on which to execute this right
that's much bigger yeah so that could so
what you're not to put words in your
mouth but i think what you're saying is
if we
cultivated an entire undersea
um
undersea
forestry with whatever i use forestry
loosely there because they do speak of
kelp forests though don't they yeah yeah
definitely we call them sea trees
okay excellent so if we developed an
entire
underwater uh plant ecosystem
as it takes carbon dioxide out of the
water
doesn't the ocean in response take
carbon dioxide out of the air yes and
that's what it's been doing for
forever right that's that's why it tries
to always stay in equilibrium if there's
a little less than one place it it
donates it back in
so this can help uh
fix the world that chuck and i destroyed
yeah that you and your your future
following after you've rendered the rest
of us extinct can have a world that you
that you embrace
exactly a livable world
just honor me what neil just said which
of course is um
um
you know a
clear path towards decarbonization um
and an effective one but
the only motivation that could really
accelerate that
would be a commercial use for the
byproduct it so do you know of any is
there any kind of seaweed based or kelp
based kind of product line that we could
and not just for your skin or something
you know chuck i got this
chuck i got this go ahead i i'm i'm done
with kale
you know i'm ready for the next thing
right and maybe it's kelp it's kelp it
is kelp yes it's so easy it is
it is okay look look when we talk about
it are you saying kelp is the new kale
it is the new kale it needs to be the
new kale
chuck they're just going down the
alphabet you know
yes it's delicious and actually a few
years ago i remember filming a segment
on one of the tv shows i hosted called
nature knows best where we were looking
at biomimicry i interviewed a kelp
farmer in connecticut who was formerly a
fisherman and was taking things out and
now began growing and doing this 3d
vertical farming model where he had
mussels and clams and then he grew
seaweed at the top and so the kelp would
grow toward the surface and it only took
a small area of the water and he was
make that was his main substance right
and people in new york city were
ordering from him because they were
making kelp pasta and all kinds of
really cool dishes with kelp it tastes
delicious
so what is the show
excuse me one of your shows you hosted i
can't
which show was that so we can find it
sure it's called exploration nature
knows best and it was back in we filmed
in 2016 to 2018 and i interviewed tons
of different people who were in
biomimicry in the space about mccree and
where do we find that you can find it on
amazon prime it used to air on saturday
mornings on fox networks around the
country it's a series it's a series it's
a series yeah there's 27 episodes
oh my gosh oh that's great okay that's
cool so you're a host to that okay i am
yes and i've hosted several different
productions
just while we're there what precisely is
biomimicry biomimicry is a study of how
we can take notes from nature and apply
them to modern technology and design and
so there are inventors and scientists
and engineers who are all doing that
right now around the world
where they're looking at nature and
looking at all the wonderful answers
that have been saw you know the problems
that have been solved within nature by
nature
why aren't we taking notes and why
aren't we mimicking what nature is
already doing we did with flight
exactly
so you're saying we're not clever enough
to do this on our own we got we need
tips from nature
who has been added for four billion
years that's what correct yes i think it
would be it's due time that we start
paying attention to the world around us
right
what a concept
oh this is very
cool and wait a minute everyone you
talked about was a woman
hmm what a surprise what's the title of
your book
the title of my book is bold women in
science and well that explains it there
you go there it is
you found them in the
you found them in the ether right okay
well cool cool it's 15 different
biographies of women throughout history
including women that are still with us
today including i'm sure she's your
friend mae jemison is in there i have
her yeah yeah i mean may go way back
yeah of course yeah may jameson a a
pioneering astronaut yeah phenomenal
shuttle era astronaut
yeah yeah so it's a fun book for
everyone um it's it's meant technically
for eight to twelve-year-olds but listen
you could sit down and read this in an
hour and like enjoy it and learn a
little something new about some women
who made some phenomenal contributions
to science every one of us knows an
eight to twelve year old somewhere in
our family or a friendship and so and
that's the age
where
oh my gosh they're where they're not
weirded out yet from middle school yeah
and
and the hormones haven't kicked in
hormones aren't interfering
oh my gosh i wish i had this book when i
was a kid literally and that's the
reason and the main reason that truly
motivated me to write it was because i
knew this is something that if i had had
this at eight years old like oh it would
be
i might have studied oceanography
but you already did it it would be so
complete it would be complete faster
faster there you go there you go yeah we
would have been having this interview
and you would be 18 years old instead of
whatever you are today right it would
have been yes yes
accelerated progress
absolutely of life
very very cool
all right so danny thanks for sharing
your time and your expertise and your
your reflections on something that not
enough people think about in this world
and we need more of that and i hope this
is not the last time you're you're
you'll be on star talk because this
topic comes up all the time and plus
we've got a whole conversation on just
just ocean conservation yeah unto itself
this one we focus mostly on your book
but there's so much more out there and
what do we do with our plastic that
that's will hold you entirely
accountable for that okay for the
solutions there okay you're holding me
accountable all right i'll bring some
solutions i got it listen yeah that's
right
i've got them i've got them and i work
with a lot of great people who do too so
excellent excellent all right danny
great to have you chuck always good to
have you on star pleasure oh you know oh
my god
neil degrasse tyson here your personal
astrophysicist as always keep looking up
[Music]
you